charles baudelaire bonsoir c'est un
honneur de vous recevoir vous le poète
du spleen l'auteur maudit des fleurs du
mâle est l'idole des adolescents qui
font autre chose que regarder la
télévision
tout le monde connaît votre vie et
pourtant les vérités et bien au-delà de
la légende vous naissez le 9 avril 1821
ce qui vous fait 181 en vous les faites
pas du tout merci mais vous savez j'ai
plus de souvenirs que si j'avais mille
ans ouais donc chambre de leur enfance
difficile je crois qu'on peut le dire
vous perdez votre père à l'âge de 6 ans
et vous reporter un amour exclusif sur
votre mère qui hélas décide de se
remarier avec le fameux commandant aupic
que vous détesterez profondément étiez
vous amoureux de votre mère oui elle fut
mon premier et mon dernier amour et je
suis mort dans ses bras voulait faire
quoi quand vous étiez enfant
je voulais être tantôt pape mais pas
militaire tantôt comédien ouais après
leur mariage de votre mère vous êtes
pensionnaires et vous n'êtes pas très
bon élève à 1 charles les premiers de la
classe vous savez ne font pas
généralement de grands auteurs alors
vous commencez charles baudelaire à
mener une vraie vie de bohème qui
scandalise votre famille un oui je
lisais beaucoup je ne l'est plus en
cours et j'ai commencé à aller voir les
prostituées à ces jeunes quand même
alors évidemment indigne et votre
famille vous poussant embarquer sur un
paquebot des mers du sud pour calcutta
ça vous a changé le voyage en asie oui
je ne suis pas revenu avec la sagesse
dans mes poches et aimé
cependant ça m'a permis de voir le culte
du beau et de la vérité alors votre
retour en france vous êtes enfin majeur
vous recevez votre héritage 75 mille
francs de l'époque ce qui fait quelques
millions d'euros aujourd'hui est-ce que
tout cet argent a changé votre vie oui
en fait j'ai pu éviter les soucis des
contingences matérielles et oui on va
c'est quand même là que vous tombez dans
la drogue et dans la luxure oui avec des
copains nommé théophile gautier un orri
de balzac et nous avons créé le club des
haschischins way et amour des paradis
artificiels 1 dans lequel nous
consommions opium et à chercher et c'est
à cette époque que je compose d'ailleurs
mes meilleurs poèmes notamment est out
au timor roumaine os je te frapperaient
son colère et sans haine comme un
boucher je ferai de thé sanglots jaillit
les zones et la souffrance c'est vrai
qu'il m'est arrivé de payer votre
barrettes de shit avec des poèmes
charles
oui mais quand on m'a privé de mon
héritage je suis devenue critique d'art
ce qui m'a permis de souvenirs de
survivre en quelque sorte et de célébrer
richard wagner et sont anna other way
alors rapidement vous dilapidez votre
héritage en menant grand train et en
achetant des faux tableaux défaut
velasquez défaut plus un mais c'est
exact ma mère à qui j'avais emprunté
beaucoup à engager contre moi une
procédure 1
et pour qu'un conseil judiciaire me
mettre sous tutelle et à partir de là
j'étais d'été pour le reste de ma vie
c'est aussi à cette époque que vous
rencontrez jeunes du val la fameuse
vénus noire une actrice à la réputation
sulfureuse elle aussi un j'ai vécu avec
elle une passion orageuse qui a duré une
vingtaine d'années ouais elle était
d'une ténébreuse beauté ouais et son
seul défaut est là ça a été de me
transmettre la syphilis vous fréquenter
assidûment les maisons closes et et vous
couchez même avec des handicapés avec
des naines vous serez même retenu en
otage dans un bordel pendant une semaine
ça s'est passé comment tiens tiens
comment savez-vous ça
[Rires]
c'est un vrai bonheur c'est votre
compagnon philoxène boyer qu'il a écrit
un nous étions partis au bordel tous les
deux et sans argent sans le sou et la du
blessé on attache pendant les semaines
dans le bordel aller jusqu'à ce que vous
avez l'argent pour payer durant le temps
où j'ai pu rassembler de l'argent pour
payer la nuit chat est ce que vous étiez
heureux dans la débauche
non vous savez après une débauche on est
toujours plus simple et plus abandonné
ouais vous qui avez ton écrit sur les
plaisirs de la chair est ce que vous
étiez un bon coup ou pas je vais vous
dire franchement plus l'homme cultive
les arts mois il bande et j'ai fait donc
bande à part alors vous contemporain
vous décrive toujours comme un dandy
très bien habillé toujours le même
costume noir à toute heure en toute
saison théodore de banville déclare même
qu'à une époque vous aviez les cheveux
teints en verre vous voyez ce qu'il ya
de plaisant dans la vie c'est de le goût
le plaisir aristocratique dirais-je de
déplaire vous étiez le premier point
qu'en fait non c'est ça oui si vous
voulez qu'on veut politiquement vous
situiez comment j'étais plutôt
anarchiste oui et tran m et il m'a
toujours paru quelque chose de créer 2
alors votre carrière d'auteur débute en
1857 quand vous publiez la première
édition complète des fleurs du mâle
contenant tous vos poèmes depuis 1840
votre livre sort mais là c'est la
boulette vous envoyer un exemplaire au
figaro oui alors ça c'est l'erreur bête
et une critiques désobligeantes et le
surlendemain d'ailleurs des poursuites
judiciaires ont été engagées contre mme
a nous étions en pleine période de
retour à l'ordre moral et j'ai été
attaqué en même temps que flaubert
madame bovary je sais plus alors le
figaro a dit pendant dix ans monsieur
baudelaire a réussi à se faire passer
pour un poète de génie il récitait des
vers
r mais il se gardait bien de les publier
et le figaro ajouté c'est de la poésie
de charniers et d'abattoirs l'odieux il
côtoie l'ignoble le repoussant saliha
l'infect ça doit faire drôle quand on
dit ça dans un journal le matin je vais
vous dire le figaro déjà il ya 150 ans
était déjà de la merde mais ça m'a fait
mal je veux dire alors là vous êtes
condamnés à 300 francs d'amendé et il
impose la suppression de six poèmes et
il vous oblige à refaire complètement
votre livre les fleurs du mal
j'avoue que ils ont plutôt détestais mon
livret jeune à mais je n'ai jamais
réussi à le refaire ouais vous êtes on
dit ah ça non pas du tout non j'avais
même peur qu'à mon époque il ne suffit
que de la différence rue qui vous a
soutenu à ce moment là quand ça allait
si mal
flaubert san boys victor hugo mais ça
devrait suffire à prêter détruits oui
malade après coup ça vous inspire quoi
cette condamnation est bien comme je les
dis à victor hugo je me trouve désormais
à l'aise mouais et devant ma flétrissure
way et je sais bien désormais dans quel
genre de littérature que je réponde je
resterai un monstre et à nougaro ouais
mais quelque chose s'est brisé en
voulant vous allez de moins en moins
résisté au plaisir de faire horreur aux
bourgeois comme vous dites vous affirmez
même avoir mangé de la cervelle d'enfant
vous montrer un livre que vous dites
relier en pot et humaines vous faites
même croire que vous avez tué
votre père et vous l'avez manger je nage
dans le déshonneur comme un poisson dans
l'eau
êtes vous ai souffert sur la fin dans
très malade
oui j'étais malade mais paralysé et
aphasique
alors est de plus en plus mal vous vous
rester pendant des mois
murray dans votre silence est la seule
phrase que vous émettez ses passements
la moutarde
j'avais la pose de celui qui regarde
passer les têtes de mort ouais alors le
31 août 1867 à 11h à 46 ans vous vous
endormez dans les bras de votre mère
vous est enterrée ou charles tout près
d'ici
oui à deux pas d'ici ma forme par le
périph un cimetière montparnasse un jean
paul sartre a écrit que vous n'aviez pas
eu la vie que vous méritiez jean paul
qui vous avez regretté de vivre dans le
péché non après tout tout littérature
dérives du péché ouais alors on vous
décrit aujourd'hui toujours comme le
dandy par excellence c'est quoi un dandy
pour vous c'est une espèce de dalmat
trop social qui ne fait rien oui il est
inutile c'est sa grandeur des grès il
vit dans devant un miroir un l'albatros
est souvent des hommes d'équipage
prennent des albatros grâce aux oiseaux
de mer qui suivent
un patient le navire de licence les
sauvages
qu'est ce qui était vraiment important
dans votre vie être un grand homme et un
simple pour soi même c'est ce qui me
paraissait le plus important
merci jean pierre joris merci beaucoup
d'avoir interprété baudelaire vous êtes
tous les soirs dans phèdre mise en scène
de jacques weber avec carole bouquet et
c'est au théâtre dejazet voilà et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux